よろしくお願いします
この無知という言葉について
あるいは鈍感という言葉について
よくあの 瞑想なんか頑張っている方々からよく聞かれる質問なんですね
だいたい瞑想を実践する方々は
自分の妄想というか 思考を確認するときは
いとも簡単に怒りなんかは発見できるんですね
これは怒りだ それから欲も発見できるんですね
これは欲ですよと そこで貪瞋痴の痴って何なのかと
これはどうやって確認すればよろしいかという
よくよく聞く聞こえる質問なんですね
で それにいろいろ何回も何回もまとめて答えたことはありますけど
見事に理解してくれないということもあるんです
それぐらいのややこしいことなんですね
無知というのは ですから
今日はちょっとその無知について考えてみましょう
で あの 今日は雨が降ってないんですけどね
まだまだ秋ですけどね
もし私たちは外に行ったら
ほんのわずかの雨の粒が体に触れて落ちてきて
またもう一つ時間経ったらもう一つ粒が触れる時もありますね
我々は全然雨だと言わないんですね
その時は 霧雨と呼べるんで
そんな大胆なことじゃもっと薄い
ほんのちょっとの水の見えないほどの一滴が体に触れてもわからないんです
先生 雨でしょ？いえいえ
雨じゃない もう大丈夫ですよと平気で言うんです
雨でありません そこで
その小さなものがどんどん回数が増えていくんです
それでどんどん粒も大きくなってくるんです
その時は手やら肩やら頭やら
あちこちにもう水が ものすごい大きな水の
あの 何て言いますか 一滴一滴
体にポツンポツンと落ちると
すっぱ雨ですよ 傘を差さなくちゃということになるんですね
それは我々誰にもある経験
私も同じことです よっぽど体濡れるぐらいもう水が落ちてこないならば
そのまま走っちゃうんです
傘差そうとは思わない
ちょっと霧雨のような感じだったら
空の状況で まあこれぐらいだったら大丈夫だと
傘を持っていかないぞと
ということにもなるんですね
私の場合だと まあとにかくその例というのはどなたでもわかっていること
ほんのちょっと一滴が一滴の水が体に落ちただけで雨とは言わない
その例をなんで申し上げたかというと
我々にとって雨ですよという理解
雨ですよという認識を作るために
大量に水がかぶってこないとわからないということなんです
かなりの量の水が上から来て
かぶってもう濡れてない限りは雨だとは認識しません
誰でも そこは事実です
そこで すっと静かに耳を澄まると言うんですか
聞いてください いろいろ聞こえるでしょ
もっともっと静かに聞いていると
もっと音が聞こえるんです
そこでもっと完璧な遮断したところで
音を遮断したところで
全く音を外から入らないところで静かに座ってみてください
何も聞こえないと思いますか？ものすごく音を聞こえるんです
体の中の音 いろいろ聞こえます
脳の中でもいろいろ信号を送るときは結構コンピューターと同じくキーキーキーという音を出しているんです
でも我々には今聞こえない
今聞こえるのは私の声だけかもしれません
時々大きな音を出して騒音を出して
車とかなんとか通ったら
まあそれは聞こえる あのわずかな音は聞こえないんです
それであの年取ってくると
どんどん耳が遠くなって鈍感になってくるんですね
いわゆる外の音が聞こえなくなってくるんですね
その時 大体の人々を言う一つの文句があるんです
よく耳鳴りがするんだ
そこで本人がなんかもうちょっと調子が良くないとかね
これを調べてもらわなくてはいけないとかね
耳鳴りなんかするとね
まあそれはいろんな他の病気の前兆でもありますと
脳出血とかね そういう前兆でもありますとかね
怖くなったりもします
実は小さい時から耳鳴りはしています
ある日突然ということじゃないんです
ただ 年とともに外の音にある感受性がどんどん衰えますから
細胞がね 受け取れなくなります
雷ぐらいの音でなきゃ聞こえなくなります
そうすると この体の中の音が聞こえて始めて
それは止まることなく聞こえるんですからね
それが耳鳴りとか何とかとか言ってるんです
だから実は外の音にちょっと鈍感になったという
衰えたというぐらいのことなんです
それで私は何を聞きたいというと
申し上げたいというと
我々は本当はずっと大量の音を受け取ってはいるんですが
認識はしていない 音は受け取ってはいますが
認識はしてありません
だから 小さなこの水の 1滴の
まあもう 10 分の 1 ぐらいの小さな水のね
そのぐらいのちょっとだけ
まああちこち体に触れても全然気が付かない
雨が降っていると それも結局は雨なんです
山の上とかね いっぱい霧に隠れている時とかね
この霧の中とか歩いてみてください
まあ霧だけですよと平気で歩くでしょうね
15 分 何 10 分ぐらい経っちゃうと全部濡れてるんです
雨ですよ ですからこの雨なんですが
雨だと認識しない そういうふうに目の場合も同じなんです
例えば目のケースは まあ私は何か皆様に見せて
カチンと見せてさっと閉めちゃう
見えますかね その場合は
見えません 例えばこの白板に何か私は隠して文字を一つ書いて
それからこの紙で隠しても
を書いて サッと見せてまた閉めちゃう
見えるんでしょうかね
見えないんです 皆さんはよく知ってる
カメラありますよ カメラっていうのは大体かなりスピードでシャッターが閉めるんですね
大体まあ  1 秒の 400分の1とかね
一般的にはそれぐらいのスピードでカメラのシャッターが閉めるんです
そうでなきゃ我々は手がブレるんだからいい写真撮れないんです
それで 1 秒の 10 分の1とかね
1 秒の60分60の1になっちゃうと
我々は当然三脚を使うんです
カメラの場合は でないと写真がもうブレちゃうというかね
そこで私たちの目では 1 秒の 400分の1っていうのはまるっきり見えないんです
なのにきちんと映像がフィルムには記録しているんです
私はこの子供二人いるしね
この子供の頃やった実験なんですけど
カメラを開けてレンズをつけるところはね
開けて これは何者かとずっとシャッターを押してみるんですね
見えません レンズから外の光は一応見えるはずということは知ってます
それでカメラの後ろの蓋を開けて
この目を合わせてシャッターを押してみたんですけど
押してはなんか動くんだけど見えません
まあそれで一番スローにスローモーションにして
一番スローっていうのはシャッターを押して指で外さない限りは開けっぱなしで
その時はなんとか見える
一応 60 分の1とか 40 分の1にしちゃうとは見えるんですね
光が入ったと だから我々の目でも大体 1 秒の半分ぐらいでも光入らないと見えないんですね
耳も同じで 目も同じで鼻も同じですよ
今 この空間で香りがないと思いますか？確実にあるんです
でもこれ大量にぶつけてこないと感じないだけ
ものすごい大量に匂いが鼻に入って
ものすごく攻撃すると
ああ 変な匂いとか言うんです
で なきゃわからないんですね
だって犬なんかはもう人間より 1万分の1の小さな匂いでも嗅ぎちゃうんです
例えばこの紙はどんな匂いか
私が嗅いでみたって全然わからない
でも それなりの訓練して犬にこれ嗅ぎ
嗅ぎ 嗅ぎっていうんですか
嗅いでもらってください
もらったらすぐ私を捕まりますからね
この人やと ですから 我々の鼻も大量の匂いが入り込まない限りは
匂いということは認識しない
味の場合も同じことでね
私はよくみんなご飯食べると見ますけどね
醤油もバンバンかけるわ
時々若い者なんかはご飯にも塩をかける
見ていられなくなっちゃうんですね
塩を食べている状態でも
で それぐらい 0.1g 0.5g
ぐらい塩がなければご飯の味が感じないと
お醤油いっぱいかけないと食べ物の味がわからないとということも我々に普通にあることで
それ私が一つこれ言いたいんです
今も舌を味を感じているんです
じゃあ唾液の 味が知ってますか？舌
自分でも味を持ってるんです
ちょっと試しに感じてみてください
味持ってます でも普通は全然感じません
だから味に鈍感な人だったら
かなり強烈に食べ物に味をつけておかないと美味しいとは言わない
体の場合も同じなんです
ものすごい激しく何か触れない限りはわからないんです
微妙に 例えば毛の先でほんのちょっと触れただけで全然わからないんです
髪の毛の先ぐらいで ちょっと体をちょっとこうやって削ってみると
削るというのと もうちょっと触れてみると
全然わかりません でもなんか指でこうやって指しちゃうとわかるんです
指でもかすかに何か触れる
触れないぐらいにしてみるとわからないんですね
そういうことで 体にしたっても
もう大量にもう爆弾みたいなデータがぶつからないと認識しないんです
そこがどんな人間にもある問題です
なんでそんなこと関係ありますかね
今日の話に だから簡単に結論を言えば
だから鈍感でしょ まあ鈍感です
それだけの結論なんです
だから普通は我々は気づくともう手遅れ
もっと大げさに言うならば
雨ですよと気づくともう濡れているんです
だから他の例に入れ替えてみると
例えば家の中でどこでもかすかにでも火とかなんとかあると
それ気づくんだったら火事にはなりません
そこでグーグーと寝ていて
家半分ぐらい焼けて ものすごい音を立てて熱くていられなくなったところで目を覚めてみたら
ああ 火事ですよ もう手遅れなんですけど
ですから 大体は人類が何かに気づくともう手遅れ
例えば今自然を破壊しているとおっしゃっているんですね
気づいたね 自然が破壊していると
もう手遅れですけど だからそこら辺が問題なんです
気づくと手遅れになっている
自分の体が病気だと気づくともう手遅れなんです
まあどうにもならん もう私も肩が随分痛いんですけど
まあ医者に聞いてみれば
これもかなり前からね
ちょっと関節とかね よく動かしておかないと
毎日毎日どんどん硬くなってくるんだよと
それで私が気づくともう治療不可能ぐらいもう手遅れなんですね
だから気づく前にちゃんと手を動かしたり
いろいろ運動したりしておいたならば
関節はちゃんと動いてくれます
ある日突然 あら 手が随分痛いのではないかと気づいたところで
もうかなり病症というかね
もう悪化してもうかなりのところまで進んでいるんですね
だからがんですよと気づくと
もう大体はまあ進行は中ぐらいにはいってるんですね
初期段階でね 気づいていければ
いとも簡単に治るものですからね
がんというのは治療も何もない
それ取っちゃえばいいんだから
でも気づくと手遅れですね
ですから 我々は人間にとってはがんというのは大変な病気だと今思ってはいるんですね
そういうことで理解してほしいのは
我々の認識の問題 鈍感ですよ
だから仏教で無知という話だから
まあもう金井氏を馬鹿にされるだろうかなとか
もうそういう誤解する必要ないよ
誰も馬鹿にしてるわけじゃないんです
まあただ事実を語ってるだけなんですね
ですから この無知と言ったっても
これは私ではないんですよと
他の人やということはちょっと成り立たないんですね
お釈迦様の教えはいつでもまあみんなそうなんですけど
という態度では聞けないんです
そうです お釈迦様おっしゃる通りです
みんなそうでいうことは言われたら
お釈迦様にすごい叱られます
違いはあなたですよと
という態度で説法するんです
だってどうでもいいって意味がないんです
例えばお釈迦様がね みんな怒りで憎しみで多大な損
自分にもするし 他人にも与えますよと言われたところで
そうですね まあそういう人々もいますよと言った
言われたところでお釈迦様に何も意味のない説法でしょうに
お釈迦様はそうではありません
あなたが怒りを抑えなさいと
あなたのことを言っているんだよ
そういうことだから 一応どんな人間でも
まあそういう鈍感というところがあるんですね
これはどうにもならんこと
何か 例えば一回目を開けて閉めただけでものは見えません
例えば この紙をこうやって見せただけで見えますかね
これを読みなければ じーっと時間をかけてこういうふうに読まなくちゃいけない
いわゆる大量のデータが入らないとわからないっていうことだ
そこでこのお醤油でもいいんですけど
あのと まあ家に浴衣には針ありますね
安全ピンやいろいろ針という
まあピンという英語でピンと言うんですけど
日本語でなんかね まあ針でお醤油に針を入れて
そこでつけますよ 針にお醤油をちゃんと
その針の先に見えるぐらい大きな一滴ではない
針の先だからね まあ毛で一番いい例なんですけどね
毛ってちょっと気持ち悪くなるかもしれません
だからね で この針ちょっと刺して
醤油の中に自分の舌に入れてみる
わかりますかね わからないんですね
そこでかなりの量を取って舌に入れてみると
まあこの醤油はどんな味かと
辛口か薄口か何なのかとわかるんですね
ということは 針の先から醤油を舐めてみても
我々にとっては無意味で意味は持たないんです
これ 日本語でどういうふうに言えばいいかわかりませんだけど
私はこの英語で自分勝手に決めた言葉なんですけど
センシブルという 別に英語でもセンシブルでもないんですけど
まあ一応そういう言葉だったら意味は通じるんじゃないかなと
このセンシブルデータ
いわゆる感じられる意味を持つという意味で
それで針先から醤油を舌に触れても意味は持たないんですね
データが入ったんですが
そのデータがセンシブルデータではありません
いわゆる意味を持つデータではないんです
そこで小指でも醤油の中に入れて小指を舐めてみると
ああ まあこれは醤油ですよとすぐわかるんです
だから大量のデータが入らないと
センシブルということが意義を意味を持つということは成り立たない
無意味になる ですから
我々はそれをないことにする
知らないんだから 認識できてないんだから
なかったことにする だから今
空気の香りは無臭ですね
香りないことにしています
自分の手なんかはね そうやって嗅いでみて
うん まあ無臭ですよと
私たちはないことにしたっても
犬に聞いてみればもう激しい匂いするんです
その区別をよく理解してほしいんです
すごい大事なポイントを説明したいんだから
まあかなりこの これ回り道を私は取ってますけど
だから私はまあ そういう随分焦って設定したんだから
英語でしか頭の中でできてないんです
まだまだ システムが とにかくセンシティブデータということで
この  日本語だったら閾値って言う
何？閾値  閾値 ああ 生きる値って
閾値って 値がその 感じられる範囲の上か下かっていう
そういう境目を  ああ なるほど
なるほど 高い はい 閾値
どうした？ この場合 私はこのデータの量のこと
量のことを一応考えて
例えば音の場合は聞こえる音
聞こえない音があるんですね
その範囲の中で犬に聞こえる音があって
人間に聞こえない 聞こえないとかね
その問題ではないんです
本当は聞こえる音なんですが
たくさん量が入らないと聞こえないということ
ちょっと違う え？そうするとちょっと違うかもしれない
例えば光の場合は赤外線は見えないのは当たり前で
紫外線も見えないのは当たり前
そうじゃなくて 視界に入る光線なんですけど
たくさん入らなきゃ見えませんと
大量にボーンと光が目にぶつからないと見え見えないということ
その量の問題なんですね
だからセンシビリティっていうのはそこで成り立つんですね
だから visibleオーディブルとか
聞こえる 見えるとか 英語の単語にそれは合わないんです
センシブル感じることはできるか
いわゆるあの感知可能な量
まあもう束縛的な話で考えましょう
自分のポケットから 1円とかね
10円とか落っこっちゃったとします
道路の中には大きな穴がありますね
下水道の落ちたと転がっちゃって
その中に行っちゃうんですね
全然 あ お金がなくなった
どうしようかと思いますかね
全然 あ 落っこっちゃった
それで終わっちゃうんです
だから損したということはそれでは感じません
そこは自分の財布が丸ごとでなくなる
その時はやっぱりお金がなくなった
どうしようかと感じるんですよ
だから どんなものにもお金がなくなったということを感じるためにも
ある量がないと 例えば料理なんか作っている間は味見たりするでしょうね
ちゃんと料理はそのまま食べてますけどね
スープを作って ちょっと小さじ 1杯くらいは飲んでみて
あ まあこれで大丈夫だとかね
はしていますけど あんたご飯食べたんでしょうか？と聞いて食べてないと言うでしょ
あれ ご飯食べたというためには
それなりの量が必要なんです
例えばご飯 1粒食べてみます
どうですか？と 味とかね
あんたご飯食べたでしょ？って言ったら
冗談じゃ食べてないんだよと言うんです
それで茶碗でご飯半分でも取って食べたならば
やっぱりご飯食べましたと言っちゃうんですね
だから １粒のご飯食べてご飯食べたと言わない
だから最低限で何粒食べればご飯食べたと言うんでしょうかと
そこら辺は量の問題なんですね
決められませんですけどね
でもあるんです 確実に
あるでしょ その事実は
ですから 例えばお金がなくなったというためには
10円ですか  50円ですか
1,000円ですかと決められません
子供なんか 50円なくなっただけでもすごいびっくりして
もう混乱してもう泣き叫んじゃいますし
大人はまあたった 50円でしょということで
もうお金なくなったということにしないんですね
その認識はしない それで若者は自分持っている全部お金財布に入れて出かけたところで
財布がなくなっちゃうと
まあお金が全部なくなったと
ものすごいショックを受けちゃう
大人がそのすべて家にある全財産を財布に入れるんではなくて
その用事に必要なものだけ財布に入れて出て行ったところで
財布がなくなっちゃうと
全財産がなくなったというショックはないんです
ですから この量もそれぞれもう随分複雑で
数字的には言えませんだけど
事実度ははっきりあります
そこまで理解できますかね
このポイントは あるセンシティブデータの量っていうのはあるんだと
いわゆる認識可能なというか
認識する量っていうのは
そしたら感度じゃないですか
まあ感度だけでは足らないんですね
センシティブといえば感度っていう意味なんですけどね
感度するって何でしょうかね
まあ一応私は感覚認識という言葉は日本語としては使いたいんですね
これは結局認識の問題だからね
赤いと認識する 青いと認識する
でも大量の赤が目に入らなきゃ赤いとは認識しない
針の先で赤が塗ってあっても
先っぽで誰もわからない
でもそれは顕微鏡で大きくしちゃうと
あ やっぱり赤いと認識します
だから顕微鏡でやっぱりこのデータの量を増やしちゃうんですね
だから英語でマグニファイと呼ぶんですからね
拡大ですからね 顕微鏡というのは拡大鏡でしょうね
拡大しなきゃ認識できません
そこはもうすべての認識についてある問題
どれぐらい量が必要でしょうか
そこですぐに私はこのセンシティブという認識可能という段階に入りたいのです
認識って何なのかと そこで我々は知っている世界
私は歴史勉強しているんだ
医学勉強しているんだ
法律を勉強しているんだとか
よく知ってる世界あるでしょうに
我々はもうなんとかなんとか会社の仕事をしているんだとか
私は女性だ 男性だとかね
我々は大量の認識を持ってるんです
大量の概念を持ってるんです
大量の知識を持ってるんです
その知識は正しいと思ってるんです
自分が知っていることだから
正しいのは当たり前だ
例えば法律家に向かって私は何かうるさいことでも言ったら
法律家が怒るんですね
あんたもう法律も何も知らないでうるさいことを言うなよと
私は法律家だから知ってますよと
ですから 法律家が私みたいに法律の ABC も知らない人が何か言っても否定されちゃうんですね
自分の知識は正しいと思うんですね
そういうふうに誰でも自分の知識が正しいと思っているんです
自分知っていることは正しい
自分見たものは見たんだから正しい
と 私は聞いたんだから正しいとと思っちゃうんですね
そこからなんですね 問題は
それであなたは知っているのはいいんだけど
あなたは大量のデータが入らなきゃ知らないでしょうと
だから我々の認識の世界っていうのは
もう爆弾爆発するみたいに大量のデータがバンバン入ったところで知っていたものなんです
１粒の水のそよぐぐらい小さな水の １滴で雨と決めたんではなくて
それの大量に水が体にかかったところで雨と認識するんだからね
雨が降ってますよと 私はもう濡れちゃったんだから知ってますよ
正しいんだよというようになるんです
ですから これを理解してください
我々の知識っていうのは
その各人が持っているこのセンシブルという認識の量の素質によって決めちゃうんですね
本当に申し訳ないんですけど
英語の単語しか思い浮かばないんですね
英語で言えばディペンズオンザレベルオブセンシビリティ
センシビリティのレベルによります
だから 人間の中で知識の差というのは当然出てきます
当たり前で出てくるんです
100円なくなったところでびっくりする人もいるし
1万円札なくなったんだけど
全く気にしない人もいるし
だからお金がなくなったと認識するためにも
人間平等ではありません
ですから 料理にみんなそれぞれ各自で塩をかけたり
胡椒をかけたりするんです
例えば料理作る人が味をつけて
あ これで料理ですよと作って食卓に持ってきても
食べる人々は自分自分でまた
味を調整しますでしょうに
ですから 私がこれが美味しいと決めても
他の人は美味しいとは決めないんですね
なので私は何か食べ物を持ったら
まあこれはもう十分塩味がありますよと言っても
他の人はやっぱり塩をちょっと入れましょうと
簡単な例っていうのは
寿司とかね 私そのまま食べるんです
で 同じものを皆様で一緒に食べると
強引に私にお醤油を入れてくれるんですね
お醤油をかけてくださいと
まあそういう親切な行為なんですけど
ちょっと大きいんですね
私にとっては 醤油を入れちゃうと
もうもうもうしょっぱくて塩味でね
なんか気持ち悪くなっちゃう
すごい辛くて それを個人の差で
だから そうやってある人の味の感覚の量と
またもう一人の人の味の感覚の量って
それでもって変わっちゃうんです
私の場合は塩味よりも
私は海苔巻いてる その味を味わいたいんですね
醤油の味じゃなくて だから入っちゃうとえらい邪魔
全部元の味をもう消しちゃいますからね
どうしても食べなさいというならば食べますけど
でもその時は澄み込むというフィックスでいくんです
もう食べるんではなくて
じゃあ澄み込みましょうと
お金がなくなったという場合でも
もう美味しいという場合でも
綺麗という場合でも 汚いという場合でも
いろんな判断の場合は
我々はこの認識の可能な量で物事を決まっているんですね
それで私は一番先にそれが鈍感だと言ったでしょうに
鈍感ですよ 認識するともう手遅れですよ
ということで 私たちにはこの眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報について正しい知識がないんです
その結論わかりますかね
目で見た故に知っているということは言えないはずなんです
目で大量なものが入ったら知ったんであって
その量も各人によって違う
例えば目の目の感情 感動性
感動の量によって この部屋はうるさい
静かとか いろんな人がいろんな意見を出すんですね
なので この部屋はうるさいという人は
自分が正しいと思ってこちらに喧嘩売ってきても
静かやと思って 何か誰か音楽でもかけてくれないかというふうに送ってきたっても
どちらでも当てにならないんです
それはその各人の主観的な問題で
感受性の問題なんです
そこで初めて主観という言葉が成り立つのです
このセンシビリティから主観というのがあったそうですね
だから おにぎり美味しいですよと言っても主観ですよ
その人の 二人がおにぎり美味しいですよと言っても
二人が別々な感受性の量を持ってますからね
別々な認識で喋っているんです
だから 永久的に我々は主観主義者たちで
共感性っていうのはないんです
みんなと一緒に分かち合うことはないんです
成り立たないんです 自分だけの世界の中にいるんです
それはこのお釈迦様の教えで
厳密にこのまあちょっとアビダンマ的みたい
アビダンマはこんなにわかりやすくは言ってないんですけど
まあ自分勝手にわかりやすく言ったってもね
それも私主観ですけど
自分にとってはね まあ明確に分析しているつもりなんです
その 主観という問題が出てきて
それでどんな人でも自分の殻の中にいるようになってしまっちゃうんですね
その機能に仏教は無知というのです
今まで説明した心理学的な機能がありますね
このセンシビリティという問題について
感受性について それに無知というわけですよ
無明というんです そういうわけで
無知無明がない人があり得るんですかね
動物でも誰でもありえないんです
神々でも誰でもありえないです
一切の生命は衆生が無知です
犬は人間より嗅覚が鋭いと言っても
犬にもわからない匂いがありますよ
犬でも匂いはね まあ 1万分の1とか
人間の感受性からね  1万分の1ぐらいに減っちゃうと大体わからないんです
やっぱりそれぐらいなければ
それで音にすごい敏感な動物たちもいますけどね
ヘビとかはね 耳はあるんだけど
感受性っていうのは随分鈍い
試しに大きい声出してヘビを起こしてみてください
起きません 耳といっても耳これはないんだけどね
耳のあのあれ 後ろの膜が外にありますけどもね
それ触るとわかりますけど
それでカエルの場合もカエルの耳がありますね
だから人間の耳の裏の膜が触っちゃうと
我々にとっては痛くてたまらないんです
例えば綿棒でも そのこの膜のところでゴソゴソとやると
ものすごい音がするでしょう
ちょっとでも早くやっちゃうと
もう痛くて痛くて でもカエルの場合は触れますよ
すごい鈍感です でもカエルの場合は
カエルにもすごい音だったら聞こえると思います
カエルの声を聞いたことはございますね
かなりすごい音なんですね
あれぐらい拡大して鳴かないと
カエル同士ではわからないんです
そこでカエルなんか捕まって
カエルの耳を指で触ってみてください
別にもう何のことないね
カエルは平気でいるんです
でも音は聞こえますから
その場合は目がね 下に沈んじゃうんです
うるさいと 私はそれあまりにも可愛くてね
カエルを捕まったので触ってみるんです
触ったら飛び出してる目がジュッと中に入っちゃう
そういうことで このカエルにしても犬にしても
動物にしても ある量のデータが入らないとわからないということ
いわゆる鈍感ということがあるのです
鈍感の度合いは各生命によって違う
ですから 幽霊の鈍感さと人間の鈍感さが違うでしょうし
神々の鈍感さと我々の鈍感さがいろいろ違うかもしれませんしね
だからといって機能は同じなんです
これまあ あまりにも専門的な話ではね
えーと 難しくなるかもしれませんですが
で 私が持っていきたいポイントというのは
このセンシビリティということで
我々は世の中を知ってるんだぞと言っても
これ自体が当て身 ならない
まず大量のデータが入らないとわからない
それで感じたものについて次に判断する
それまた当てにならないでしょうに
その場合は いろんなセンシビリティの世界で感じる世界の差が出てくるのです
例えば 1番目はこの 人間だけに言っちゃうと
まあ人間誰でも一般的に感じること
例えばお腹が空いたとかね
眠いとか痛いとか暑いとかね
一応どんな人間も感じる
じゃあそれで暑いということは
私も感じる 皆さんも感じる
どんな人間も感じます
寒いということも感じます
では それで我々に共感性ありますか？ないんですよ
だって 日本の方々は暑いということと
エジプトの方々は暑いということは違いますからね
随分違います エジプトやエチオピアではね
昼間になると毎日 40度に軽々く行きます
その人 毎日暑い暑いと言ってますかね
普通ですからね 私たちにとってはもう 40度っていうのは
ちょっと想像できないお風呂の状態だから
私も 40度の風呂には全く入れません
ですから 暑いということもみんな共通のように見えるんだけど
結局は共通じゃないんです
例えばものを見て白いですよと
誰でも白い そうでもない
白いという色についても
それぞれの人間がやっぱりそれでもいろいろ思っています
例えばお腹が空いたんだということは
生命 みんなのお腹が空く
空くでしょ 日本人のお腹も空くし
アフリカ人のお腹も空くし
西洋人のお腹も空きますけど
でもお腹が空いたというところでも
それぞれの人の考え方はまた違うんです
時々 1 日 1回しか食べない食べられない人々もいます
1 日 1回しか食べられない人が
今日 1 日食べたならば
今日 1 日お腹が空いたと言いますかね
言わないんです 感じ方は変わるんです
で テレビで見たんですけど
アフリカの方なんですけど
自分の国もすごい元気な
ものすごい健康な体格の人でしたけど
まあ一回しか食べないとか何とかでしょうね
で そっちは食べません
すごい元気ですけど そこでその人は日本にいるにいるんだから
1 日 3回でも4回でも食べられるでしょうに
日本でも食べません 一回しか
だから その人と日本人が友達になっても
友達が日本人がもうもう 1 日 3回
4回ぐらいお腹が空いたと言うし
あの人は何も言わないし
今日お腹が空いたと言ったら一回で
また明日になってお腹が空いたら何か食べようということになるんですね
ですから お腹が空いたという感じさえも
今例に出したアフリカの方が 1 日一回言うことです
でも日本人だったら 1 日 3回
4回ぐらい ものになっちゃうんですね
だからやっぱり残念なことに共通性がなくなっちゃうんですね
客観性ってのは それ一つ共通
みんなに同じ 主観についてのそんな問題問題なんです
それから この各民族によって
各人類によって また感じ方が違う
例えば美しいと感じることは
人類は同じく感じるはずでしょう
みんな同じ生物学的にホモサピエンスだから
美しいということは ただ
チンパンジーだったら
チンパンジーのメスがすごい美人だと思っているでしょうね
人間の女性見て あ 美人だとか
もう追っかけましょうとかね
あれ 何といいますか あれ
男たちやること 話しかけることはなんとか言うでしょ
女性に なんて言いますか
みんなやってるでしょ
道路で女の人が見たら
なんかちょっと話をかけて
え？誘惑じゃない え？ナンパ
私なんか知ってます  例えば言いたかったのは
あのチンパンジーは決して人間の女性をナンパしません
笑い チンパンジーのメスだったらもうナンパしようとする
だから美しいということは
それぞれの生命によって違うんですね
それで我々みんな人間だから
じゃあ同じことに美しいと感じるかというと
そこでまた差が出てきて
日本の美と西洋の美っていうのは違う
インド人の美感覚また違う
インド人が綺麗という話と日本人が綺麗という話がそういうもん違う
どこかの国では あの女性っていうのは体がドラム缶みたいにまるまる太っていないと美人では受け取れない
だからみんなものすごく体格が大きい
女性たちが 男たちは普通
それで結構まあ人気あるんですね
それで日本の人々に聞いたら
全くもう反対考え方なんですね
骸骨でなければ美人ではないと
だからそのそこ感覚が違うんですね
そこで南アジアというか
この南インドとかね そこら辺に行くと
この女性はよくアクセサリーつけるんですね
それで耳から耳の下の上で
もうこちらで こちらこちら
もうここはここからここまでとかね
ものアクセサリーばっかしで
だからその場合はいっぱいつけた方が金属をね
まあまあ ほとんど金とか銀とかですけどね
体に金属は量たくさんつけたら美しいと
でもあれほどは決していくらお金あっても日本の女性はつけません
特別なことでつけるかもしれませんが
じゃつけませんね だから美しく見せるということで
アクセサリーつける場合でも
それぞれ認識が違うんです
それで文化的に民族的な差っていうのは
日本人はご飯美味しいというし
西洋人はパン美味しいというし
我々インド文化文化系はご飯だったらカレー
カレーの文化だよと思っちゃうし
こちらは醤油文化だよと思っちゃう
そうやっていろいろ民族的に差が出てくる
年代的にも差が出てくる
子供にとって美しいものは
大人にとっては面白くないんですね
大人綺麗というものには子供は綺麗とは思わない
とやって そこの中でも差が出てくるのです
それから我々はいろいろ勉強したりしますね
いろんなことを勉強したり
考えたり 研究したりします
それで知識が増えるんです
それでもってセンシビリティのレベルがまた変わっちゃうんです
例えば同じ絵を見ても
絵のことを勉強している人の感受性と全く知らない人の感受性違うでしょ
同じ曲を音楽家聞く 普通の人が聞く
二人の受け方が違うんです
そういうのは大体一般的な知識だからお分かりになると思いますけど
そこでまあ子供もなんとかなんとかね
息を吸ったり吐いたりして歌ってるでしょうに
子供の場合はまあ息を吐きながら歌って
また吸うながらも歌いますからね
大人みたいにちゃんと息を吐いて
それで歌って 次また息を吸って歌うってことはないんです
まあまあ それはまあ子供の歌い方ですけどね
で その場合も子供がまあ変な歌い方ですけど
まあもう音声とかなんとも何もないしね
それでも親が子供が歌ってくれるとすごい喜んじゃうんですね
ああ 上手に歌えたと拍手まであげると送るとか
同じく他人の子供を歌っても
まあそんなにダメじゃないですかね
ですから そうやって感受性っていうのは変わるもんだ
それは知識の問題で だから知識ある人と知識ない人の感受性もまた変わる
何かについて研究した人の知識と
研究していない人の知識
ですから 我々のこのセンシブルという私が書いた言葉
センシビリティー 感受性で理解してみましょう
この感受性というものは
勉強によっても 研究によっても
思考によってもまた変わってしまっちゃうんですね
それからくだらん妄想をするでしょう
あれやこれやとかね 私はあまりいい人間じゃないんだとかね
まあ不幸な人間だとかね
別に証拠があってるわけじゃないけど
ほとんど妄想する場合は
まあいい加減に同じことをずっと妄想しちゃうんですね
私のことをみんな嫌っているとかね
そうやって妄想しちゃうと
その本人に見える世界はまた変わっていくんです
私のことみんな気になってるんだと思った
思って そういう妄想を持っていっちゃうと
世の中に生きてるといつでもその人に見える世界が変わっていくんです
例えば精神的な病気になった人は
私のことをみんな批判しているんだぞと
その妄想を働かせちゃうと
人が何喋ろうが関係なく
あの人は私のことを批判しているんだよと
そうすると私たちがあんた何言ってるんですか？と
その人にとってはあなたのことは関係ないんだよと言うんです
そうすると その人の反応があなたは鈍感だからわからないだけでしょうと
私のはよくわかっているんだよ
と言うんです 確かにあの人は私の悪口言ってるんだ
それはこの妄想やら幻覚やら作っちゃうと
さらにこの感受性が変わってしまっちゃうんです
だから本人が自分知ったという世界が正しいと思っています
どうにもならん 大変なことなんです
これは それだけじゃない
また 5番目もあります
私はこのまあセンシビリティーということは
いろんな条件で変わりますよということを今説明
5つ言いましたけど  4つ言いましたけど
5番目 いろんなことを信じる
信仰する 例えば確かに神様がいると信仰してみてください
すべてその目で見えるんです
すべてその目で見える
例えば不思議な動物を見たら
やっぱりとてもとても神様がよくもそういう風に考えてお作りになったんですねとかね
例えばこの あの動物 このカンガルーいますね
カンガルーの赤ちゃんというのは 1 センチ
ぐらいの長さ ものすごい小さい
なんかまあまあ  4 分に切ったミミズぐらいなんですね
だからこのお腹の中小さいし
生殖器官も全部相当小さいんだから
まあ小さい なんかこのウジ虫みたいぐらいの小さなカンガルーが生まれてくるんです
それでもアリにでも食べられちゃいますよ
それで不思議なこと その小さなカンガルーの赤ちゃんには
お腹の上へ登るぐらいの記録を遺伝に書かれているんですね
それでなんとか登って袋がありますね
その袋の中に入り込んじゃうんです
そこで袋の中に子供がいても
このカンガルーのお母さんだよと全然わかりません
その中で長い間おっぱいを飲んで大きくなるんです
全て神様が作ったんだぞと思っちゃう人にとっては
なんて不思議でしょうかね
そういうふうに幽体というんですか
あれは作家ね そういうふうに幽体すると
その中でおっぱい作ってあげなかったら
カンガルーの赤ちゃんが死ぬんではないかと
それ うまくできてるもんだなとかね
やっぱりさすが神様ではなくて
そんなことは設計することは無理と
言って その人にとっては
カンガルーにしても神様がいるということで証拠になる
ですから いろいろ信仰
それから固定概念 それからマインドコントロール
なども我々の知識を左右するんです
認識を左右させちゃうんです
例えば 神様が信じない私たちにとっては
あの まあいろんな生命は生命
生き方というのは その環境に合わせてできていることで
おなかの中で子どもを育てられない場合は
卵にして産んで逃げちゃうとかね
それで卵の中から出てくると 1
年前 それだけでそういうものもいるし
ずっとつきっきりで面倒を見なくちゃいけない生命もいるし
それなりに我々の生活は変わっているんです
もし人間の体にも 例えば空間がなくて
空きがなくて それから体力がないと骨が弱くて
そうするとおなかの中で大きな赤ちゃんをつけておくことはできないんです
ぶら下がっていることは体が壊れちゃいます
骨が折れます その場合は人間も卵を産むでしょう
おそらく そうであったならば
もし将来人間の体がそうやって変わってしまって
骨がもろくなったと 体の中の空洞もどんどん細くなったと
体がすごい軽い方が生きやすくて
重くなったら死ぬんだぞという状態になったら
人間も卵で産む産む可能性はないわけじゃないんです
そんなことは同じ DNA だからね
アミバからみんな持ってるの
もうハエよりはもうちょっとちょっとだけでしょ
大きいのは人間の DNA っていうのは
ですから そんなもの不思議ということでもない
ですから そういうふうに考える人には
そういうふうに見える
神様という絶対的な神様がつくつくするんだという概念を作っている
作っている人には違う角度で見える
だからこのオクトパス
わかりますか？タコでタコがすごい変身しますね
やっぱり神様がタコが身を守るためによくついてあげて
作ってあげ 作ってあげたんでしょうと思うかもしれません
で 普通の自然法則だと思っている人にとっては
まあそれは自然法則だからね
そうやって身を守るためにいろいろ工夫ができているんだと
どちらにでも証拠 例えば
そのタコの変身というのは
タコが見た世界に限っちゃうでしょうに
一度も見たことがないことには変身しません
ですから タコは違う環境に入れちゃうと
その環境に合わせて変身する
それで自然の主義を持ってる人は
だからこれは自然の原因やと
いえ それで神様を信仰する人は
だから神様はその環境に合わせるように作っているんだと
赤い色は全くないところのタコは赤い色にはなりません
なのに 赤い色のところに連れて行っちゃったところで
もう赤い色になることできるでしょうよ
神様でなきゃできません
そんなこと そういう風に我々の知識っていうのは
自分を得た信仰 信仰というのはちょっと失礼な言葉なんですけど
一応ビリーフですよ 信仰です
まあ宗教的でなくても
例えば科学信仰しているでしょうに
科学も一つの信仰でしょうに
まあいろんなことをみんな信仰しているし
証拠ないんだけど正しいと思っていることは信仰なんです
ただの神様を信じることだけ信仰というわけじゃないんです
我々もいろんなことを信仰して生きています
ですから このそれによっても認識というのはもう変わってしまっちゃう
マインドコントロールによっても変わる
それで私の質問は ですから
知識は当てになりますか？と
そんなにも知識に執着して私が知ってるんだという一言葉言えますかと
我々にとってはすべての問題
そこから出てくるんです
私が知ってるんだ そこから苦しみしか生まれてこないんです
あの人は私の悪口言ってるんだ
私は知ってるんだ 言って自分が苦しみを作る
この人は私をいじめているんだと
それで苦しみを作る いや
いじめてないんで あなたうるさいこと言わない
失礼なこと 被害者は私ですから
いじめられたのは私ですから
あんたわかるわけないでしょうと
怒鳴られたりまでする
そこで この人に私がいじめられているんだと思ったこと自体は認識でしょ
大量にデータが入ったところの判断でしょ
当てにならない ある人がちょっと一言葉もいじめだと思う
ある人が滅多なことをされない限りはいじめやと思わない
例えば ある若奥さんが姑さんにちょっとこの味噌汁はね
ちょっと薄いんじゃないかなと
ああそうと言って ああそう
じゃあちょっと濃い味にしますよという奥さんもいるかもしれませんし
それだけのことでなんだいちいちうるさくて
何にもケチつけてるんではないかといじめているんではないかと思う奥さんもあり得るでしょうに
だからいじめられているんだと言ったっても
それまたその各人によって違います
学校にしたっても いじめられているとかいじめ問題とかしたっても
それやっぱり主観なんです
まあ蹴られただけで カバンを隠しただけで
まあいじめられているんだというふうに受け取る子供もいるし
それは全然いじめやと思わないで
一生懸命自分のカバンどこにありますか？どこにありますかと必死になって捜し込むいるし
だから必死になって捜す子は別にそれぐらいのことはいじめだと思わない
時々殴られてもいじめだと思わない子供がいるんです
臭いと言われただけでいじめだと思う人もいる
私はいろいろ子供を見たところでも
時々もうあんた臭いんだからと言われたら
わざわざと着て体につけたり
いろんなことをする子もいる
だからその場合は その子はいじめやと思ってないんです
ああそうだったらもっとやってやるぞと
それでまた他の子は臭いと言われただけで
いきなりもうガコンと落ち込んじゃって
自信がなくなって暗くなるという場合もあります
ですから それはどこから生まれる問題かというと
この私が知ってるんだということから生まれるんですよ
この知ってるんだっていうことは
本当は鈍感の結果なんです
営々の結果じゃないんです
それは最初から説明していたんです
それが無知の世界なんです
そこで紹介文章にもあったように
このなんで私はこうなったんでしょうか？とかね
こんなはずではなかったとか
みんな文句言うでしょうに
いろんな不幸に出会っちゃうと
こんなはずではなかったと
なんで私にこんなこと起こるんですか？とか疑問に思ったりする時あるでしょうね
気づくともう手遅れだけで
ある人がなんで私にが私がガンになるんですかと
私が聞くんです 私は何も返事できませんけど
心の中では当たり前ではないかという立場なんですけど
だから これはこの微妙なところから
ほんのちょっと ほんのちょっと始めたことで
ものすごい手遅れぐらい大きくなったら気づいただけ
だから子供がいきなり不良になったとかね
いきなり子供がおかしくなったとか
母が混乱したっても何も意味ないんです
ほんのちょっと ほんのちょっと
母親も周りもその原因を作っていたんです
ただ気がつかないだけ
あまりにも小さいことだから
時々ほんのわずかなことで子供を馬鹿にするとかね
だってそれわからないままですね
どうたことどうたことないんではないかと
まあ無関心でいますけど
でもやがてそれ積み重なって爆発しちゃうんです
その時はなんでここまでいい子ない
いい子でいたのに 突然悪くなったんでしょうかと驚いちゃって
いろいろあっちこち走り回って相談に乗ってもらったっても
実は手遅れなんです だから我々作る問題も
ある日突然会社が倒産したとかね
それはありえないんです
会社の社員たちが毎秒
毎分 毎時 毎日やっている行為の結果なんです
で 最後に倒産になる 例えばほんのちょっとの判断ミスを捨てたりする
まあまあ それぐらい全然大丈夫やとそこで無視する
ほんのちょっとの商売で
ちょっとまあ 1 万  2 万ぐらいは損したりする
まあまあ それぐらいは当然なことで関係ないよとか
それで無視する それで 2
3 年で会社が丸ごとに倒産したところでびっくりと
そういうことで みんながこの無知で大変な不幸を招くんです
ある日突然何か起こるということはないんです
ちゃんと順番で 例えば雨っていうのは
ある日突然降るわけじゃないんです
突然 空からいきなりドーンと水が落ちたってことはないんです
ゆっくりゆっくりと空気が変わって
空気の流れが変わって
雲が集めて もうそれから微妙に空気の湿気が高くなって
もうゆっくりと順番で
それから大粒の雨が降るようになるんです
だから大粒の雨が降った瞬間だけで我々は気づく
ただそれだけ です でも答えとかどうすればいいかっていうことはね
どうすればいいんですかね
その場合は どんな人間もそういう問題で悩んでます
だから我々はもう 本来は無知
針の先で醤油の味はわからないんだという状態なんです
髪の毛 1本だけ体に触れても
そんなことはわかりませんという状態で生きているんです
かなり触れないと そういうことで
この我々はデータを大量の束にして知ってるんです
そこら辺は瞑想でなきゃわからないんです
どれぐらいデータが入ったら認識するかとかね
その個人のレベルを個人個人で発見するしか方法ないんです
自分のことだからね そこでこの
1 秒の 100分の 間で
絵やら人の顔やらちゃんと入ってます
入ってるんだけど知らない
で また入るんです それでも知らない
それで 0.5 秒ぐらい
たくさん映像が入るんです
光の速度を知っているでしょうに
だから考えてみてください
光の速度で映像一つ目に入っちゃうんです
丸ごと 1枚映るんです
光の速度で そこで光の速度で丸ごと 1枚映像を映るんだけど
見えてない  大体 0.3 ぐらいとかね
0.4 ぐらい 映っちゃうとかすかに見えるんです
ということは 我々は映像をたくさん
もう無数に 何枚も重ねて束にして
あ この人の顔ですと判断しちゃうんです
お釈迦様はチャレンジしたいのは
できれば 1 枚進めてください
1 枚進めてください 音は音視探人で見てください
映像はこうして見てみてください
そうすると 今まで作った私が知っているという
あの妄想の世界 あのサンニャーの世界
あの幻覚の世界 すぐ壊れちゃう
すべて根拠のなかったものになる
すべて主観でしたから
同時にすべての苦しみも問題も消えるんです
だから 仏教の悟りというのは智慧の完成なんです
無知の反対なんです 解決方法はそれしかないんです
他のもう何やっても 要は祈りして巡礼して治りますか？その問題は
この認識の問題は 何をしたっても治りません
お経をあげて 大目をあげて治ると思いますかね
治らないんです 大目を開ける方々でも
人生は不幸だとかね もっとより精神的な
清らかな人間にならなくちゃあかんだとか思ってやっているでしょうに
私から見れば馬鹿もいいところなんですけど
そんな判断さえも間違っているし
これやればもう心軽やかになるんだぞと思ったこと自体間違っているし
もともと認識をちゃんとしっかりしないといけないということですからね
そういうことで我々は見ているのは自分の主観で
例えば 1億枚の映像が重ねたら見えたという人もいて
5000 枚の映像を積み重ね重ねたら見えたという人もいるんです
どちらにでも見えてないんです
ただ感受性の差があるだけで
ですから 私たち知ってる世界っていうのは
強引にこの合成した世界なんです
例えば光っていうのは一番早いでしょうに
目を開けたらそれぐらい速さで
この映像がずっと入ってるんです
でも閉じていて パッと開けてパッと閉めただけで見えません
ということは もの大量に枚数が入らないと
その入った枚数を頭の中で自分で合成するんです
合成してあ 見えた見えたと言うんです
だから 3人で見て あ あれは面白い
もう一人はいい あれ面白くないとかね
いろいろ言うんです 例えばヘビを見て
ああ 気持ち悪いという人もいるし
ヘビ可愛いんじゃないかと言ってペットに飼う人もいるでしょうに
なんでしょうかね それは
ヘビを見たら気持ち悪いと思う人がそういう風に合成する
大量の枚数の映像をね
頭に入れてごちゃ混ぜにして合成して
ああ 気持ち悪いと決める
もう一人の人は同じく大量の映像を頭に入れて合成して
可愛いんじゃないかと
と決める だからヘビは気持ち悪い
ヘビは可愛いとどちらでも同じことで当てにならない
妄想概念にしか何もないんです
夢中の世界っていうのはそんなもな世界で
だからお釈迦様が解決方法として
やっぱりこのありのままに
瞬間瞬間 物事を観察してください
判断しないで観察してみてくださいと
見えるものは見える 見えると
音だったら音 音だけで
そこでうまくいくということではなくて
どんどんそれやっていると
感受性がどんどん鋭くなるんです
あの 例えば億枚でなければ見えなかった人に
まあ五千枚で見えるようになるんです
どんどん千枚で見えるようにもなるんです
で そういうことで この感受性が高く
敏感になればなるほど
世界観がやっぱり自動的に変わっていくんです
今まで自分が作った主観の世界っていうのは当てにならないということがわかって
ああ もうそれからはもう脱する
それ悩むことはやめる
消すということでもなくて
まあこれはまあただ主観です
さらに見ていると 物事っていうのはずっと変わってるんだっていう
自分も見る人も見られるものも変わっていくんだよっていうことで
まあそんなもんだと ことで心が解脱ということは体験するんですね
だからそういう過程で無明無知なくしたければ
解脱するということしか方法はないんです
で 厳密な話はそこら辺にで
まあ終了します  これからちょっと休憩して
一般的な話をいたします
ありがとうございます
では 講演始まります で
あの この前の説明から考えると
我々は知っている世界というのはだいたい当てにならないということまで話を進めました
ですから 我々はこれをどのように人生にするかというと
あまりこう自分知ってる世界
あんまりしがみつかない方がいいんです
勉強したものであろうとも
聞いたことであろうとも
自分の主観だからね その時はやっぱり気をつける
それは消せませんよ 勉強したものやらね
知ったこととか 消すこと意味ではないんですよ
まあ例えば喋る場合 まあ私だったらこういう風に思いますよと
私だったらこういう風にしますよと
そういう風な この他人に言う習慣つけて
自分の判断は必ずしも正しいということは自分で見てみないと
例えば誰かがどうすればいいんでしょうかと
いう場合は いえ こうしなさいよと言うのは無知な人の生き方で
そうではなくて その人が一応どうすればいいかと聞いたんだから
そうですね まあ私だったらおそらくこういう風にするでしょうと言って
はっきりと自分の主観を言う
自分の主観しかないんだから
でも 故にそれが正しいというわけじゃないんです
私だったら一応こういう風にするでしょうという風に言ってある
そうすると 相手の人が自分の主観がなるほど
これが正しいと思ったら勝手にやるでしょうし
あるいはいえ 違いますよと思ったならば
それは違いますと言うでしょうし
私たちの問題は 相手に勉強しなさいと言ったら
嫌ですよと言われると腹が立つんですよ
なんで嫌と言うんでしょうかと
そこがもうトラブルの元なんです
だから まあ私だったら今の時間で真面目に勉強しますよと言ったところで
向こうがいや 嫌ですよと言うかもしれません
でも それはその人の主観から見れば
勉強するのは嫌ということですからね
ああ そうですかと そういう風に
あの いわゆる執着しない知識の世界をゆっくりと育てる必要があるんです
それをそれだけでものすごく頭が良くなるんです
例えばこれは塩辛いというんじゃなくて
まあ私にとってはちょっと塩辛く感じますよと
そうするとトラブルが起こりません
例えば 人がせっかく一生懸命褒めてもらいたくて
褒めてもらいたくて料理を作ったとする
まあもともと褒めてもらいたくて料理を作った人は
その時点でもう愚か者であることは確かですけどね
でも その人はこれはまずいと言われちゃうと大変な出来事になるんです
あるいは逆にもうまずいものを作っちゃって
それ食べて強引にこうやって笑っておいしいですよと言うのは
個人自分にとってはね
大変損するし まずいものはまずいと言った方が自分にとっては得でしょうし
だからどうすればいいかと
その場合は まあ私だったらもうちょっと柔らかい方がいいでしょうとかね
まあ私の感覚ではもうちょっと味があった方がいいと思いますよとかね
それはあくまでも私の感覚ではと言ったら
本人から見れば いや 自分にとっても
例えば本人がいえ これは最高のおいしい
あ そうですね それで終わっちゃう
問題解決します  相手に相手方の立場から見れば
これは最高に美味しいんですけど
まあこちらの主観から見れば
もうちょっと味を付けた方がいいって
まあただ味を付けた方がいいという
まあ個人的な意見だけですよと言えば全然トラブルは起こりません
なんでそういう風に喋られますかというと
自分の知識は絶対的正しいという立場を取ってないんだから
この今まで説明した話から
それ正しくなるはずがない
それを理解しておけば
すごく気楽にトラブルを起こさずに生きていられます
人間には だからそういう風にしようしてください
子供が母親父は何か言う場合も
これやれ これやるではなくて
まあ私がこういう風なことをやってほしいなとかね
自分の意見 言うと 父親がいえ
これはまあこういうわけで
私はあまりやってあげたくないんですよとかね
と言ったところで喧嘩にはなりません
そういうことだったらいくらか話し合いということも成り立つ
今 我々はいっぱいディスカッションやら会議やらやってますけど
みんな自分の主観 自分の我見をバンバン出すだけであって
誰も聞いてない  20人集めたら 20人もこれだ
これだ これだと言うだけで
一人一人が自分が言っていることはその通りで正しいんだ
そんなことは会議にもディスカッションにも話し合いにも何にもなりません
私もかなりそういうことでもう痛めつけられているんだから
で こちらは人の意見は聞きますけど
聞いたんだからって その意見は完璧に正しいということじゃないでしょうに
そこでいろんな他の意見と取らし合わせて
まあいくらか有効なプラクティカルな意見は一応作ったところで
向こう側が機嫌が悪い
私の意見が無視されたんだそうと
じゃあ私は参加しませんと
という態度を取っちゃうんですね
それはあまりにも我執であまりにも我見に囚われて
あまりにも無知なんですね
そうすると人間付き合いっていうのはまるっきり成り立たない
大変なことですよ 二人が話し合うということは
もともと成り立たないことだから
いわゆる何て言いますか
共同的な経験ないんだから
お腹が空いたと言っても同じ経験じゃないでしょうに
だからもともと成り立たないことをやってますよ
人と仲良くするということは
その上我執でいると もうどうにもならんです
だからそういう人々は社会から追い出される
じゃあ私は辞めますと
その人には平気で言われる
辞めて楽しいかというと
だから喧嘩して辞めただけである
なんだかんだでも辞めることも知恵ではないし
物事をうまく運ぶことが知恵なんです
嫌だから辞めたというのも
バカだから辞めたということでしょうし
だから世の中でなんだかんだいや
辞める 辞める そんな簡単ではないんですけど
知恵のある人はなんだかんだ辞める
辞めるではなくて 有効にみんなのためにどうやってこれ運ぶかと
それを考えるんです ですから
みんなの意見を聞いて
それを合わせてみて それなりにいろいろ調停をして
どんな意見が通用できるかないかということは決めなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 我々はよく平和で無事で
それから仲良く 社会人間として幸福で生きていきたければ
この無知ということには随分気をつけることなんです
気をつけて我見に我執にとらわれない
そうすると喧嘩ということは成り立たないんです
喧嘩が成り立たないということは
決して意見違いはあり得ないということではありませんよ
夫婦は別々な意見はあるかもしれませんよ
別々意見を持っても喧嘩にはなりません
で 相手はまあ 私の意見では
私の気持ちとしてはこういうことだよと
向こう側が全く違うことを言うかもしれません
いきなり暴言があって
なんでそんなことあんたそんなこと言うんでしょうかと
いきなりもうコブラみたいにもうかかっていくでしょう
それが愚か者の愚か者なんです
自分の意見に全く正反対のことを言っても
ああ そうですか それだけのことなんです
それはその人の意見でしょうし
こちらはこちらの意見でしょうし
どちらにしたっても主観だから
この当てになるものじゃないし
相手が自分の意見すごい正しい
そんなにいちいち神経質にならなくて
落ち着きなさいよと 人っていうのはいろいろ意見持っているんだからとか
もっと大人になりなさいよと
青い色は好きな人もいて
嫌いな人もいて いろいろいるんだから
という風に言ってあげればいいでしょう
だからこの 特に日本にあること
この強引にまとめるという和合とか
あんなうるさい嘘ばっかし言って和合も調和もないんです
この社会でも  私の悪口で言えば
日本で何がないかというと和合と調和なんです
でも日本の方々は 日本文化として日本は世界に売るものだと
和合と調和だよと言ってるでしょうに
でも私は別に外国人としてではなくて
一つの仏教として出家僧と喋る場合は
日本人に何がないかというと
和合と調和なんです だって
会社にしたっても 学校にしたっても
家にしたっても 強引に決まり決め
決めて 強引に無理やりそれに合わせているんです
これが和合じゃなくて
もう残酷 何て言いますかね
虐待というかね もうあまりにも残酷なんです
トーチャーという言葉
英語でありますね トーチャー
何だったっけ あの拷問に使う言葉なんですけど
ものすごく痛めつけて
まあ拷問なんです だからみんな結局拷問されちゃって怖くて合わせているだけじゃないんですかね
それが和合と調和ということは言えますかね
仏教の立場からですよ
私は一外国人として見ると
もう確かにまあ和合と調和がありますよと言いますけど
仏教徒としては言いません
ブッダの立場からは言いません
だから本当に和合と調和があると
すごく気楽で穏やかで
ストレスも何もなくて
なんど美しいんですよ
一人が二人になる そちらに和合成り立つでしょう
ものすごい穏やかになるんです
3人になるともっと立派な和合ができるんだから
ずいぶん気楽になるはずなんです
実際はどうですかね 実際はどうですか
人の数が増えれば増えるほど
ものすごい窮屈と結束になるでしょう
だから仏教っていうのは
この全ての価値観を捨てる世界だから
残念なことに日本の価値観は捨てなくちゃいけないんです
西洋と比べて日本の価値観は素晴らしいけど
それは比較するだけのことで
どんな価値観も捨てなくちゃいけないんです
それでなきゃ幸せっていうのは出てこないんです
だから和合 調和っていうのは素晴らしいこと
これをお釈迦様は認めています
何にでも和合で調和でやらなきゃ
もう苦しいんだよと 仲良く仲良くと
でもそれが世の中でないんです
お釈迦様は仲良くということは
自分の主観に 自分の我見にしがみついていることじゃないんです
それがあまりもアホくさいと
自分の主観 我見というのはね
みんなそれぞれ我見ばっかり持っていて
お互いに罵り合ったり
ぶつかっているんだよと
だから大人はみんなの意見は
その場合はまあその見えますよと
こういう風にも言えますよと
では我々みんな集めて
どういう風にすればよろしいかなとかね
みんなで考えましょうと
それが和合なんです みんなで考えたら反対意見ないはずなんです
これでこの世界でみんなで考えましょうで考えて結論を出したところで
俺が反対 だから変えると
ああ なるほどと私は思いますね
ですから 仏教では民主主義なんですけど
多数決じゃないんです
お釈迦様は多数決は認めません
お釈迦様にとっては 多数決っていうのは民主主義ではなくて独裁主義
だって多数の意見でしょ
少数はどうしますか？独裁なんです
100人集めたところで
99人一つの意見 一人が違う意見
仏教だったら通じません
99人の意見だからそれにしましょうとと言ったところ
一人の意見は 独裁です 90
人の だから90人の意見を
我々いうのは 100人集めたところで 90
人も違う意見を持っている
一人がまた違う意見を持っている
それで一人が自分の意見を通してもらう
そうすると我々は独裁と言うんですね
独断判断であんたよくやってるんだよとかね
批判するでしょ 仏教は両方
我々俗世間では90人の意見だから
我々はしっかりと民主主義でやっていますよと
仏教は違います それも独裁的に 90
人の意見を抑えて一人の意見を通しちゃうと
それは独裁的に だから話し合うということは
お互いに話し合って 話し合って
それぞれの意見の長も短もね
考えてみて そういうことだから
こういう風にしましょうと決めることなんですよ
そうすると それはみんなの意見でなければいけません
誰にも反対する権利はないんです
みんなで話し合って作った意見だから
ですから 仏教の民主主義っていうのは善因一致ということになっているんです
わかりますかね お釈迦様が考えている和合と調和っていうのは
どれほど厳密かと だからそれは通用しているのは出家の世界だけ
お釈迦様はどうせ話聞いてくれないということを知っていたんだから
出家組織を作ったんです
別に出家しなきゃ悟れないとか
そんなことは非科学的だからね
は言ってないんですけど
どうも言うことを聞いてくれないし
まあとにかくモデルでもね
サンプルでもね 作っておきましょうと
ということで お釈迦様は自分の知恵から見た平和な世界
問題を作らない世界をね
特別にまあ人々を取って
ある組織を作ってみたんです
だからサンガの世界では個人の意見は通りません
主観は通りません 個人で財産さえ持ってはいけないんです
常に和合でやらなくちゃいけない
異論だったらすぐ話し合いなさいと
みんなで話し合ってうまくいかないんだったら
大騒ぎになるんだったら
人数 人数が大きくて それだったら
なんていうのは審査会作りなさい
賢者たちの何人かと 例えば 100人のお坊さんがいて
もう一人がなんかすごい変な意見を出したとします
すると 100人のお坊さんたちもいろいろ意見言うわ言うわで
もうどうしても落ち着いてこないんですね
その場合はすぐサンガがどうしますかというと
この 100人のお坊さんたちの中から一番智慧のある
一番優秀な一人 二人選んで審査会を設定するわけです
そこで審査会で調べるんです
その一つの問題 調べて審査会で判決を出すんです
正しい意見はこういう意見だといって
この審査会とこの問題を起こした人と
みんなまたサンガの八人の集まりに入って
じゃあ発表いたしますと
レスラーが発表します
そうするとみんな全員一致でじゃあ賛成します
反対はできません 反対できませんと言ったら
なんかすごい厳しいではないかと
それどういう意味の反対ではないんです
それが和合であって 調和なんです
もう仏教に基づいて 戒律に基づいて
審査会の長老たちがきちんと判断したんだから
個人の私の好みではダメですよ
ということになるんです
ですから この理想的な民主主義っていうのは
サンガサンガの世界でのみあるんであって
普通の世界ではありえないし
ないんです 不可能というわけじゃない
もうちょっと頭が良ければ
人間に和合っていうのは作れますよ
そういうことだから この幸せで豊かで生きていきたければ
すごい簡単なポイントっていうのは
あまり私意見に囚われないこと
です 捨てなさいということではありません
捨てられるものじゃないんだから
それが私意見だと 私見だと
肉が嫌いという人がいるならば
じゃあ捨てなさいよ あなたの考え方はと
肉は美味しいと思いながら言ったって無理でしょうに
ニンジン嫌いやと思ってる人がいるんだったら
あんたそんな主観でね
何やってるんですか？と
みんな食べてる食べ物だから好きになりなさいと言ったって
こんな無理な話で ですから
自分の私見を捨てなさいということではなくて
私見にとらわれてはいけないというぐらいのことなんです
ですから まあ私にとってはニンジンはちょっと口に合わないんですよと言えば
みんなそうでしょうかね
まあ我々にとっては美味しいんですけど
じゃあそこらへん何とかしましょうと
あなたのためにニンジン抜きに料理しましょうと
ふうになっちゃうし あるいはあなたのためにニンジン抜き料理はできませんが
ニンジンを取って食べられるように作りますよというぐらいの調和が成り立せるでしょうに
独裁主義だったら じゃあニンジンを潰してペースト状態に作って料理に入れましょうと
そうすると ニンジン嫌いな人には嫌いなものは取ることさえできなくなっちゃうでしょうね
それが独裁的なやり方
調和っていうのは ニンジン嫌いな人にニンジン好きになりなさいということではないんです
今の社会ではそうさせてるんです
学校に行っても 会社に行っても
激しい規則にしきたりに決まりに縛られてるんで
地方によってもうわけもわからない決まりしきたりっていうのがいっぱいあって
他の地方から遊びに行った人だったら
もう地獄の苦しみなんですね
何もわからないんだから
そこは調和とは言えません
そんなものは拷問すぎなんです
だから 東京の女の子が随分遠い東北とかどこでもいいんですけど
遊びに行ったならば まあそこは全く考え方と世界と違いますから
ゆっくりゆっくりお互いの意見を交わし合って
友好な生き方を作ればいいでしょうに
それがこの無知で悩まない方法なんですね
無知の人は仏教では愚か者と呼ぶんですね
だから愚か 愚か者っていうことは
私は何回も文章を書きましたから
これは差別用語ではありません
これはみんなにまとめて言ってることやろ
愚か者でないというのは主観を捨てた人だけですよ
それはもう悟らなきゃ
だから今説明した この今は現代風に心理学的にちょっと論理的に説明したんだからね
無知の過程をね ですから
そこを仰ってるだけなんです
だから愚か者と言って
お釈迦様がこういうふうに教えるんですよ
この世の中で危険が生まれるならば
すべては愚か者から生まれる
智慧のある人からは生まれません
災難が生まれるならば
愚か者から無知の人から災難が生まれる
賢者からは災難が生まれませんと
大損 ものすごい損すること
一応 3つの言葉ありますけど
ほとんど危険 災難ぐらいでもわかりますね
人がものすごく損していて
すごい悲しいことになるんだったら
これは愚か者の結果ですよ
決して賢者はそれからはそういうものは生まれてこない
こないんだ そこでお釈迦様はだいたいすべてすべてとか
総括的な言葉っていうのは気をつけて使う
例えば みんなそうですよというのはものすごいいい加減な言い方でしょうよ
これだったらみんな嫌いますよとみんな簡単に言うでしょ
お釈迦様はそんなこと言わないですよ
これはみんな嫌いますよと言ったって
みんなに聞かなきゃわからないことでしょう
だからみんなすべて一切
それは一番気をつけなくちゃいけない言葉なんですね
でもこの場合 お釈迦様はすべてという言葉をちゃんと使っているんです
一切という言葉を使っているんです
ヤーニカーニチビッカレバヤーニウパージャニウパージャンティサッバーニターニバーラトウパージャンティサッブイッサ
恐怖感が生まれるならば
すべてが愚か者から生まれる
愚か者のせいで生まれるんだ
これいわば無知のせいで生まれるんだよ
だから恐怖感嫌だと 災難嫌だと悲しみ嫌だ
損するのは嫌だと思うんだったら
この我々は主観にしがみつくことをやめる
それで結論を出します
お釈迦様が イティコビッケサッパティバヨバード
故に比丘らよ 愚か者というのはものすごい危険である
アッパティバヨバンディト
賢者は 危険から平安なところですよ
安全なところ 避難所ですよ
そう パッダをバーデ 愚か者というのはいつでも悩むことを作るものやと
アヌパッダをバンディト
賢者は悩むことを消すんだと
そう ウパーサカゴバード
愚か者が災難ですよ 賢者が平安ですよ
ですから 愚か者と賢者を区別しなさいよと
だから私も愚か者になってはいけないし
それから人と付き合う時も気をつけないといけないんですよ
愚か者がね 主観主義者が言うことに乗せられちゃうと必ず危険があるのです
必ず だから我々は簡単に人の意見に乗せられるという状態
振り回される状態っていうのは
これは自分がもう本当に判断能力がないということになっちゃうんです
人の意見は客観的に聞く
自分の意見も客観的にする
そうすると振り回される
乗せられるということはないんですね
だから我々はまあいくらもう社会で生きていたっても
人の意見を聞きながらやっぱり注意する必要があるんです
この人はあまりにも主観で喋っているか
客観的に情報を取って発表ぐらいしているんでしょうかどうかね
ただ 自分の意見 私の意見こそ正しいんだから
これやれという独裁的な感じで言うんでしょうかどうか
チェックできるでしょうに
チェックしたら この人は愚か者であると
ですから危険の種ですよと
火種ですよと それで気をつけましょうと
火種でも何か道具で使っちゃうとね
別に手は火傷しませんだからね
それで愚か者を判断する方法っていうのはいろいろありまして
体で何かやろうとしたら
これまた悪いことばっかりやる
かえどっちゃいと悪いことする
喋ると悪い言葉を喋る
考えると変ないけないことは考える
それ知られるでしょうに
人が何かやっていることを見ると
それは行儀のよろしい立派な行為か
品のないいい加減な行為か
すぐ見えるでしょうに
それだけでわかります
喋ると言葉はすごく気をつけて客観的に喋りますか？あるいは感情的になって
私はこういうことだという風に喋るかとかね
あまりにも主観的で激しく喋るんだったら
まあもう智慧がないということなんですね
なので 人の考え方はもう聞いたらわかるでしょうに
私はこういう意見だ こういう意見だと言うで
それ意見聞いてみたら
なんか変な意見だと おかしい意見だと
ものすごい偏見的だとわかったら
まあこの人は要注意にするんです
それで この人が無知な人であると
この人は愚か者であると誰に理解できますか？というと
みんなに理解できません
賢者にのみ理解できる
今おっしゃったのは賢者になる方法なんですね
まあ完璧になる方法ではなくて
まあ賢者もどきみたいかもしれませんし
賢者かぶりかもしれませんし
やっぱりそれでもうまくいくんです
自分の主観は主観であることは認識して
まあ私の意見はこういうふうな意見なんですけどという態度で生きてみる
私から見ればこういうふうなことになりますけどとかね
そうやってこの主観にとらわれないように訓練すると
まあいくらか賢者かぶりかもしれませんだけど
修行してないんだから
でもそれでもしなきゃ
それ決して悪いことじゃないんです
そうすると相手のことがわかります
自分が主観主義だったら
決して相手のことはわからない
例えば喧嘩するときは
みんな感情的に言いたい放題のことばっかり言って喧嘩するでしょうに
誰も人の話聞いてないでしょ
終わってから聞いてみてください
相手であなたはこういうことを言ったと
はい 言いましたと 相手はどのように反応したんでしょうかと
全然聞いてないんです
だから愚か者に愚か者の判断はできません
だから賢者が人の話を見て
人の行為を見て 人の思考を見て
この人は無知な人であると決める
決めて身の安全を図る
もう一つあります この愚か者の判断できる方法っていうのは
愚か者っていうのは間違いを認めないんです
いろいろ失敗するでしょうね
変なことするで間違いを起こすでしょうに
愚か者が間違いを認めません
全然認めません これで賢者が自分が間違ったら
あ 間違えましたと あ これ私に
あ これは間違えましたと
これが失敗ですよとすぐ認める
堂々と それだけですごい立派な人なんです
だからみんなごまかしする
言い回しをする 隠せようとする
間違い だから自分の失敗
自分の間違い ごまかすならば
隠そうとするならば 自分自身が正真正銘の愚か者なんです
そこで相手のことを見てやっても
相手がもう間違っているのに全然認めないこと
よくごまかすこととかわかるでしょうね
そうすると相手も無知な人やと
そこで間違っても愚か者が直さないんですよ
それでいいやと 間違って何が悪いんですか？と言いながらまた間違っちゃうんです
大体いくら仏教は慈しみの世界と言ったっても
仏様は三回までと言うんだから二回までです
それ以上はもう付き合わない
もう出て行く 時間の無駄だと
ですから 間違いしたら教えてあげたりする
それでも直さない場合とかね
態度変えて だから何でしょうかとかね
それぐらいはいいんじゃないかと
ったら賢者が まあまあ
それぐらいは別にどうったことはないんですけど
間違いを認めて直してくださいと言っても
また間違いをするんだったら
また言ってあげる また間違いをしたらまた言ってあげる
それで終わり 付き合いも終わり
そうでなきゃこの世の中できていられません
だから賢者 愚か者のやり方っていうのは
間違いはまず認めない
それから直さない それからもう一つあります
他人の間違いは決して許さない
これ 愚か者の生き方なんです
例えば何か間違いを起こしたら
ごめんなさいとかね おわびしますとかね
他人が言ったら まあそれそれでなかったことにするんですよ
賢者 ああそう じゃあまあまあいい
もうそんなこと関係ないと
じゃあなかったことにしましょうと
本気でなかったことにします
賢者は 間違いは相手の間違いは
愚か者の場合は相手の相手が間違って
すみません すみません
もう間違えました ごめんなさいと言って
言ったいくら言ったっても怒鳴ったり
いろんなことをしたりするんです
一生忘れません それだけは頭が悪いは悪いには
人のこうやって過ちだけはずっと覚えておく
それが愚か者の生き方なんですね
それでこの無知な人の判断してください
好意で それから失敗っても誰でもするんだからね
だからよく簡単に判断できます
失敗したら あ これは失敗や
なんのことなく認める人がもうかなり立派な人なんです
人の失敗はまあまあいいんじゃないかなと許してあげるんだったら
もう立派なことなんです
それから 話し合う時も無知な人を発見できます
例えば質問する時はよく考えて質問しない
とにかく質問する いわゆる質問というのは
何か疑問が起きて あるいは例えば私の場合
私が言ったことについて何か疑問が起きて
もう自分の意見があって
そこでもうぶつかったりすると
そこは質問をしましょうという風に明確に質問を作らなくちゃいけないんですね
そうじゃなくて とにかくもう何か言ったら何か言う
これ何かでまた何か言うという
これも気をつけた方がいいんです
ってなって 私はもう体持てなくなっちゃってるんです
最近本当に考えないで質問する人々いるんですね
私は明確に見せてあげるんです
あんたは何も考えてないんだと
ところで また逆にそうではなくて
こうではないか ああではないか
また来るんです そこで私はまあ
2回目でストップするわけです
例は出せますけど これはまああまり良くないんだからね
それからこの愚か者に質問しても明確に答えないんですね
なんとかごまかす なんとかそうでもああでもなんとか言ってなんとか言い返す
そこで頭のいい人は質問されたら
その質問を綺麗に分析して綺麗に答えるんです
きちんと ただ言い返しだけで答えじゃないんです
だから質問に答える時でも
頭が知恵のある人かない人かということはわかるんです
それからもう一つ 例えば宗教の世界でもね
私が言うことには当然異論というのはありますからね
世の中は違う意見を持ってるんだから
それで違う意見を持ってる人が話し合いになる
例えば私にできるわけじゃないんだけど
私は明確に分析して証拠を出して
出して まあこういうことですよときちんと説得させても
でも認めません と言うと
もう正真正銘の愚か者です
異論があって質問出されたところで
それには厳密に答えたならば
答えが正しければ認めるべきなんです
いや 私は 20年こういうことをやってきたんだから
やめませんと だったらどうしよう
こちらに関係ある人ではありませんということになるんです
だから 知恵のある人の判断というのは
その 2つ 質問すると もうあんまりぐちゃぐちゃで
質問自体は明確じゃない
答える時でもなんとか言い返するだけであって
もう全部把握して答えようとしない
それで答えられた場合でも
きちんと納得させてくれたのに認めないという 3つのポイント
覚えておいてください
例えば あの人にはいくら説明しても認めて認めませんとやってくれませんと言ったら
その人は頑固ということでしょう
人の話を聞かないということでしょう
自分の意見にしがみついているということですよ
もう愚か者です 例えば
私だったら絶対こんなことは認めませんと言っている人でも
話し合った結果 やっぱり考え方を直しますと言ったならば
もう頭のいい人なんです
そういうふうなことで
知恵のない人が人のことを判断できます
それからもう一つ この愚か者っていうのは
愚か者の生き方 無知な人の生き方っていうのは
この自分の穴を自分で掘る生き方なんです
自分の墓穴を自分で掘る
いわゆる自分自分を掘ってるんです
自我を 自己を だから人の生き方を見て
この人は自己破壊ではないかと
そんなことしたら 例えば子供があまり勉強しないと
どうせ自己破壊の道でしょうに
だからもう勉強しないんだったら頭が悪いということにどうせなるしね
頭が悪くても一生懸命真面目に苦労して勉強しちゃうと
この子は自分の将来を考えているんですね
だから 嫌だから勉強しませんよとかね
難しいんだからしませんよと言ったら自己破壊なんですよ
それはもう愚か者の判断の基準なんでね
大人にしたって同じことで
この悪いこととか何とか
こんなことやったら自己破壊ですよと
例えば金は無駄遣いするわ
特に収入を得るように頑張らないと自己破壊でしょうに
無知な人なんですね 例えばいろいろ依存症で
アルコールやらタバコやら賭け物
競馬やらね いろんなものに依存して
そこで快楽を感じると
明確に自己破壊の道でしょうに
そうやって自己破壊の道に行く人々は
もうまとめて無知な人ということになるんです
知恵のある人がいつでも自分のことを気をつけて
自己破壊へは行ってはいけないということで気をつけるんです
子供から大人まで で あの無知な人の判断はそれぐらいでできます
で そういうふうに判断して
我々は気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
それで私たち個人でも
本当に鈍感でないようにと気をつけなくてはいけないんですね
ですから この修行しなくても瞑想すると
これを厳密にこの心理のレベルで解決しますけど
みんなに修行できるわけでもないし
時間もないんだから 日常生活の中に我々はよく目を開けておく
耳をよく開いておく いわゆるものをよく見る
人の話もよく聞く 理解する
そういう生き方をしなくちゃいけない
あまり主観に 主観に囚われないようにする
大体私はこういうものだ
こういうものだとか決めない方がいいんですよ
ということはね まあ私は日本人だからこれしか食べませんよとかね
別に何の意味もないんですけどね
そんなこと言ったっても
私はこういう地方でしか住めませんよとかね
私はこんな感じの人としか付き合いませんよとかね
そうやってこの硬い私を作らない方がいいんです
すごく自我を柔軟性 になるようにする
そういうことで目を開けておく
耳を開いておく 目も耳も
私たちも子供の頃言われた言葉がありまして
あんた知ってますか？人には目はいくつありますかと
じゃあ 2つですよと 耳はいくつありますか？ 2つですよ
では口は？口は一つですよ
それはなぜでしょうかと聞いたら
目は 2つあるんだから
ものをよく2倍見なさいと
耳が 2つあるんだから
物事をよく聞きなさいよ
口一つありますから 喋る時はすごく気をつけて少なく喋りますね
ですから やっぱり正しく情報を受けるということを教えていて
喋る時は随分気をつけて
自分の主観はボンボン出すのではなくて
気をつけていると結構うまくいくと思います
と それから まあ大体まあ大きなポイントっていうのは
まあまあそれぞれそれぐらいで全部終わりますけど
まあ細かい細かいことをまたいろいろ言えますしね
まあそれもう一つポイントはあります
それで終了します 貪瞋痴を発見する方法
例えば綺麗な何か見たらすごい可愛い
犬見たら可愛いとすぐわかりますね
綺麗な花を見たら すごい綺麗な花ですよ
すぐわかります それが欲ですね
すぐわかります それで嫌なことを聞いたら
まあ嫌な音ですよとかね
嫌なものを口に入れたら
あ これは嫌いですよと
すぐわかります だから人っていうのは
この怒りと欲っていうのは簡単にわかります
でも 怒りと欲が無知という土台で現れるものなんです
無知という土台が一貫してみんなにあるんです
修行しない限りは それで怒りと欲が怒りと欲出てくるんですね
それでこういうふうなことを無知がよく働くんですね
例えば 何か見たら面白いと思ってそれに惹かれる
それが欲 面白くない 嫌いだと思っちゃうと
それから離れる それに攻撃する
それが怒り 他のものとしては
我々はあまり面白くないと無視する
だから 1時間生きてみると
あ 面白いとかね あ 嫌ということっていうのはほとんど少ないんです
1時間ただぼーっと座ってみましょう
いろんな音が聞こえる
いろんなものは見えるし
その 1時間の間であ すごい面白いと惹かれる感覚っていうのは少ないでしょうし
それが嫌だとかね 気持ち悪いというふうに攻撃したくなる感覚も少ないでしょ
大体 1時間ぼーっと座っていると
なんとなく面白くないというかね
軽々く面白くないとかね
退屈とかね ということになるんです
その時は我々は無視という行動をするんです
惹かれるか 反発するか
無視するか ものについて対象に
怒れるか 対象に反発するか
あるいは無視するか 無視する間は無知が機能しているんです
ということで 我々は 1時間間でかなりの量に無知を育てるんです
大変な問題です それを直す方法っていうのは
やっぱりどんなものにも興味を持って興味に溢れる人間になります
そうするとみるみるうちに頭が良くなるんです
今 テレビでも料理研究家やら片付けのプロやらとか
いろんなくだらないことにまでプロがいるでしょう
片付けのプロがいるんだそうと
インテリアのプロがいるんだそうと
それでインテリアの中でもカラーコーディネーションのプロがいるんだとかね
料理はあまりできないんだけど
この料理を設定することのプロがいるんだとか
商売は下手なんですけど
店のディスプレイの陳列するときのプロがいるとかね
それでいろんなくだらないことにまでプロがいる世界でしょ
なんでそんなになるんでしょうか
で その人々はある一つのものにすごい興味を持ってるんです
よくテレビでね 放送時間でもたくさん使っているのは女性のお化粧のためですからね
それでこの痩せて見せる方法とかね
目がより大きく見せる方法とかね
そういう幻覚のプロがいるんですね
目は目なんですけど お化粧でいろいろハイライトしたり
シャドウを入れたり いろんな工夫をして
まあ大きく見せる 唇は本当にものすごい太いなんですけど
まあお化粧の仕方によって細く見せるとかね
それもプロがいて すごいお金を取る
で 私が言いたいのは どんなものにも
これ何？なんでこういう風にあるんでしょうか？というね
そうやってどんなものにも興味を持つと
人生一貫して面白いんです
家にゴキブリがいた途端
いきなり怒りが来て ああ
嫌だとかやきやるんじゃなくて
どんな形のゴキブリですかとかね
歩き方はどういうことですかとかね
どこに隠れているんでしょうかとかね
それについての興味を持つ
どんなつまらないことでも興味を持つと
そのそのことからすごく喜びも出てくるし
頭も良くなるし だからこの科学者っていうのは
子供の頃から何かに凝って興味を持つ人々でしょ
だから ある一つに興味を持つんではなくて
一般的に人生について
毎日の出来事について
電車に乗ったら電車にいる人々について
立ち方について  ちょっと見てみるとかね
私みたいに電車に乗ったら
いろいろ広告あるでしょ
全部読みますから 今は目が見えなくなって読めなくなっちゃったんだけどね
大きな文字以外は ですから
まあでも読める時は全部読む
別にそれでもって何か知識ではなくて
やっぱり何か知識を得られるんです
それでもって私はみんなどうやって何を考えているか
まあどういう風に騙されているでしょうかとかね
全部騙し文句だからね
こんなものにも騙される人いるでしょとかね
だからそんな広告書いてるんだぞとかね
それで私はかなり勉強になるんです
みんなの思考パターンまで広告読んだだけで
それで全く屁理屈で論理的には何も関係ないんだけど
いろいろつなげているとかね
これこれとこれ何にも関係ないのに繋げて広告出しているということは
人間がなんとか好き勝手につなげるでしょうとかね
すごい人気のある人の顔写真を出して
もうもうろくに役に立たない品物はそこに置いておく
それでみんな買っちゃうんです
そういう人間の弱み握ってるところとかね
愚かさ握ってますけど
弱みっていうと だからそうやって電車に乗ったら
そこら辺にもいろんなことに興味を持つ
毎日ご飯を炊くかもしれませんけど
毎日違うんだよと 毎日とくご飯にしたっても
毎日興味を持つ 毎日の掃除でもマンネリではなくて
毎日違いますよ で 興味を持つ
そうすると あの無知という機能が消えちゃう
それで智慧が現れてくると思います
それですごく楽しく生きていられます
退屈っていうのはなくなっちゃうんです
いつでも精神的に元気で青年でいられます
では 話はそこら辺で終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
時間の方はちょっと過ぎてるんですが
あの ちょっと質問のある方はしていただいても大丈夫です
どうぞ遠慮しないで はい
質問します あの愚か者を見た時に
その人が自分の意見をガンガン言って直さないという時に
まあこの人はいいやというふうにしちゃうと
同じ会社の中で仕事してる場合に
人間関係がすごい悪くなってくるんですね
ですから 基本的なスタンスとしては
やっぱりまあ慈しみの心といいますか
そういうものがありっちゃいけないのかなという気はしてるんですけども
ですから その賢者はもうあの人はいいやというふうに言えるかもしれない
してないんですが 愚か者が愚か者に対すると時には
もうちょっと違うやり方を選ばないといけないのかなというふうに思ったんですけども
何かいいアドバイス  実践してみたら多分問題になりませんと思いますけども
まあ自分が主観出さないんだったらぶつからないんだからね
だから最初から言ったんだから
自分が まあ私の場合はこういう意見ですと言ってあげれば
相手が自分の主観はいくら頑固でガンガン言ったってもね
ぶつからないんです だから人間関係悪くなるのは
私の意見 これでしょ？これ聞きなさいと立場取っちゃうとなんです
ですから 問題に全くなりません
人間関係まずくなりません
まずくなるのは あの人
あんな意見持ってるんだけど
絶対認めませんよということがない
ないんですね だから無視してやるぞと
すると立場がまずいんです
ではなくて まあその人はそういう意見で
まあ私だったらこういう意見ですけど
ということで止まるんだから問題にはならないんですね
そこでどうしても付き合う場合はね
例えばその人の意見が全く違うとわかっても
まあ本当はね まあ私たちはこういうふうなことをしますけど
まあそちらはまあ本当に反対であるということはよくわかりますけど
申し訳ないんですよと言っちゃえばそれだけです
まあ反対ということはよくよく知ってますけど
その理由も知ってますけど
でも今の場合はちょっと申し訳ない
ちょっと勘弁してくれと
それぐらい知恵使うんです
で それから本当にとんでもない悪いこと
危険なことばっかりやってる時でも
付き合う方法はあるんですね
ものすごい熱いものはどうやって取るんですか？ 布かなんかで
何かな取るでしょう だから取って取らないことないんです
だから注意気づくという道具をいつでも前に持っていく
慈悲というのはもっと違う次元のことで
生命は幸せでいてほしいということでね
ですから 人には攻撃しないということでね
賢者もあんた出て行けと言ったって慈悲がないわけじゃないんです
慈悲で言ってるんです
追い出されたところで
その人は気づく可能性もあるし
あるいは逆に愚か者に一生賢者の時間でなく時間がなくなっちゃう
育てられる人々は 1万人
2万人ももうダメになっちゃう
それ自体が どれほどいけないかということ
だから賢者が慈悲を持って追い出すんです
あなたに付き合うために私は 3時間使ってもあなたは理解はしません
でも この 3時間で他の人々だったら 100人でも心が直りますよ
だから 100人地獄に落とすんですかね
あるバカ者と付き合うために付き合ったっても
その人は天界に行かないんだから
自分を直さないんだからね
それはしょうがないんです
だから近所の態度っていうのは
やっぱりそれ自体も慈しみの行為なんですけど
まあ我々はやっぱりどんな生命でも幸福でいてほしいっていうことは基本的なことでね
それとこれぶつかれないんです
どうですか？いかがでしょうか
もう一声とかありましたらどうぞ
センシブルっていうことについて
センシティブですか あの先ほどのお話で
まあ理解が間違っていなければ
あの生命 生命体がね 何かをセンシブルな状態になった時はもう遅いというふうにおっしゃったと思うんですが
人間に限らずですね 全ての生命というのは
あの どっか世界の片隅に生きているわけですね
魚は水の中とか 人間はまあこういうところです
ミミズは土の中に住む
で その自分が住んでいる片隅の中で
生命体として生きるわけですから
その片隅の中で その生きるっていうことは
おそらく内外からの情報を分析して
自分の自分が生きるために必要な情報をキャッチして
また危険が迫れば逃げる
生きるために必要な栄養分を取るとか
必要最小限の情報をキャッチしてると思うんですね
例えばミミズで言えばよくわかりますが
例えば音ですね 振動は俺のついてる感覚じゃないですか
その時にその非常に微細な振動だと
アリが近づいてくる音まで感じる必要はある
しかし そのミミズの外部にやはりイノシシだとしましてね
イノシシが近づいてくる時に
イノシシの音をキャッチした瞬間にもう逃げられなければ逃げ出して生きられませんから
おそらくそのイノシシの足音のイノシシが危険なところに近づいてくる
そういった程度のところでイノシシが振動をキャッチするようにできてると思うんですね
ですから その感じた瞬間にもう遅いということじゃなくて
センシティブっていうことは
そのミミズならミミズの生存に必要な
その十分手前の段階でセンシティブになるんじゃないかなというふうに思うんですが
ですから だからそのセンシブルミミズは自分の生命に危険のある振動をキャッチするタイミングというのは
自分のやっぱりアリの音を感じないというアリの足音を感じないと
例えば それはその自分の自分の生存にとって必要な
十分必要な安全 自分の安全を確保するために
十分ゆとりを持った段階でそのセンシティブになるようにできているんだって
ですから その不必要な音に対しては無知であるとは思いますけれども
センシティブになった瞬間にもう遅いということはないんじゃないかっていうのはちょっとするんですけども
あのお釈迦様の教えと直接関係はないですけど
まあ別におっしゃってることはまあ
ね それはまあ当たり前のことだと思いますけど
だから犬に犬は音に敏感でいる必要でしょうし
で まあコウモリはね 超音波までキャッチできるのはコウモリにとっては夜飛ぶんだからね
それは必要でしょうし
だから必要なセンシビリティーということはね
あって生きてるんですよということだと思いますけどね
ですから 人間の場合 その
なんていうと さっき先ほどのお話で何かをまたは音を
だからとにかくその質問
質問ではなくて意見成り立つののは
生生きることは最高やという固定概念がある限りなんです
私にとっては生というのは最高やと
どうやって決めるかという
また まあそういうのは
それ固定概念でセンシビリティーが変わっちゃうんですね
だから仏教は正ではなくて解脱ということを言ってるんだから
まあセンシビリティーは足りませんと
今の論理取ってみたっても
じゃあ今我々持ってるセンシビリティーでうまく生きているんだよと
ということは うまく生きるためにはセンシビリティーが必要なんですね
じゃあセンシビリティーが鋭くなったらもっとうまく生きていられるでしょ？じゃあセンシビリティーが完全に完成したら完成になるでしょうに
だから別に問題ないと思いますけど
だから私のポイントはセンシビリティー
センシビリティーは足りませんと
空いてるもので我々はもうもう満足してるんだけど
それ自体無知鈍感だよと
だからこのイノシシの音が聞こえるぐらいの音に反応するミミズがイノシシに食われるでしょうに
うん 結局は アリは随分敏感なんですけど
あのアリクイがいるんですね
あの動物に全部片っ端から食べられちゃうし
人間が生きるためにセンシビリティを持ってるんだけど
事故を起こしちゃうといろんなことで殺されちゃうし
人が見たらこの人はやばいとわかるんだけど
やっぱり殺されちゃうんでしょ
結局持ってるセンシビリティではろくな結果がないんです
なんとかガタガタ生きてるだけ
だから苦しみは消えないんです
人間の世界でも戦争は絶えないし
憎しみ絶えないし 苦しみが絶えないし
もうずっとあるでしょうに
動物の世界でもそうでしょうね
動物は鋭い感覚を持ってるんだけど
絶滅状態になってるでしょうに
だから足らないんですね
結局は だからセンシビリティということは
これぐらい鈍感なセンシビリティでなんとか生きてるんだから
もうちょっとセンシビリティあればどうでしょうかと
そこであの長老がおっしゃった中で
例えばそのものを見るというところに合成して
束が束にして見ていたと
ただ その十分に その瞑想ですか
修練を積めばですね その束の瞬間をずっと縮めていって
一瞬にしてものをものを見るというか
そういうちょっとわかりませんけども
それはその 私なんかのあれではものを
私がものを見ているというもの姿じゃなくて
ある一瞬に何を見る？ その時に何も成り立ちません
私も成り立ちませんし
世界も成り立ちません
ですから だからすべて崩れるんです
幻想の世界が そこで初めて真理の世界で
そこで初めて無常が出てくるのです
無常と無執着っていうのは
それは悟りの世界でありますから
人間の知識ではもう理解できるっていうことは成り立ちませんね
普段ものを見ているものがある
顕在意識とかそんな次元の話じゃないわけですね
だから関係がないです
じゃあよろしいですか
時間の方もちょっと参りましたので
あとちょっと処刑館に行ってお話はもらわなければいけませんけど
ここで一回回向ので審査される
皆さんはどうも  仏法僧の三宝を敬い
敬し神の如き日の瞑想とヴィパッサナー瞑想によって作られたものと崇め
並びに先祖と両親に親みと孝に仕え始めとし
一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして唱えられます サッビーティオーイワンジャントサンバゴーウィナッサトゥマーテーラワットアンテラーヨースキーリーラーユコーガヴァーヴァワトゥサンバマンガランワッサン
とサンバディーターサンバブッダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマハヌバーヴェーナサンバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダー スッティバワントゥテーアビワーベナシーリッ
セーニッチャンヴァッダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーヴァッダンティーヤーユワンノースカンバラン
では どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます